[Applause]
it's my story okay listen up now to all
my parents out there now it's been a
little rough for a while now but you're
doing a great job and you know it give
yourselves a pat on the back
no matter how you feel inside you're
doing a good job this pandemic isn't
easy
but a new study finds that many parents
actually do kind of feel like they are
superheroes when it comes to their kids
the good news network reports a poll of
2 000 parents found the majority said
that they discovered superhuman reflexes
within two months of having their kids
that's me like the crazy uh baby
catching reflex oh yeah i've done that
or having the ability to have eyes in
the back of your head yep we've all done
that you know when your child is sick
just by looking at them we all have that
power kim drew
what superhuman powers do you think you
guys have attained since having a baby
it's like sleep deprivation with a cape
let me tell you something the night i
stay up and still go to work the next
day it was unbelievable your eyes are
burning but you power through uh i have
super
hearing i heard the baby i'm telling you
way down the hallway i just said i was
like oh my god he needs me
uh you can there's so many things you
didn't know as a parent i adopted my son
at four days old and i was like oh my
god i didn't have them i'm not gonna
have all the things that mothers have i
got every last bit of it oh
[Applause]
[Music]
both girls my superpower is
that was my restrained
i was thinking about it just so that
when they argue with each other or they
try to pull those stunts because they
don't want to go to bed
that whole
el eva let's you know it's time we're
not going to play these
these games you know what i mean but
i wasn't raised that way because my mom
used to be like getting to bed i'm a
count 10 9.
you wait till they get to about three
and then you take off running because
you know what comes at one mm-hmm but if
i start counting with these new age kids
they finish counting for me
they start clapping like we did it
yeah and i'm like you're not playing the
game right
now but they don't even understand or
give you none of that patience so your
super power is patience yeah what a good
dad you are
girl dad that's so fun two girl club yes
two girls two girls i love that kid
am i gonna have kids i don't know if i'm
gonna have kids we had our uh uh
wellington's nephews over and i got
they're like 10 or 30 they're over each
i don't know
no i i was like
i don't know how old they are they're
they're somewhere between 10 and 25. and
i was like hello oh how are you i don't
know how to be around kids necessarily i
don't know i don't have but i think
that's a superh power you get when you
have kids suddenly yeah like my mom her
superpower she had like a thermometer in
her hand i'd always be like do i have a
fever and she'd just touch me and be
like no
yes yes no i mean there's those things
as a parent you get i do not have those
things right now could it happen it's
gonna be it could well if it happens
it'll be on purpose we're not gonna have
any mistakes that's for sure
filming a surprise babies here
gross all right
all right well you know let me move on
i'm moving on all right you know life is
full of milestones weddings having
babies baby showers and now there's
another celebration people are having a
divorce party yeah okay the blog purewow
reports people are throwing their newly
divorced pals a little sore to celebrate
a fresh start so if you've got a friend
who could use a pump up party here are
some tips to throw a divorce party for
yourself keep it intimate they say keep
it upbeat they say get it catered nobody
wants to cook buy a big cake and bring
some thoughtful gifts i say get a pinata
made that looks like your ex
that's a party
[Applause]
here's what i was just thinking
sometimes that can get a little messy
only because the people
your friends and your
ex-wife's friends
they're the same friends a lot of times
so you're inviting half of those friends
to your divorce party which means
they're telling the other friends which
means it gets back to the person that's
being divorced and she told two friends
and they told you and divorce
both sides aren't usually as happy
equally happy somebody either still
wants to get back together or somebody's
you know hanging on the hope so i don't
know somebody that's just like i'm
getting divorced finally that just makes
things worse especially when kids are
involved i think you should invite your
friends from college you know what i
mean the friends you've had for a
million yeah they got to be their
original friends that told you not to
get married in the first place
yeah those ones
you had to let go because you got
married
[Music]